when I was young I found an orphaned
wolf cub in the forest 9r farm I felt if
I could instill rules the proper
boundaries I could harness at a lot of
power of that beasts
a few months later while hunting lesson
turned me
we're fixing the damage the Avengers did
all those years ago Inhumans are sick
unlimited power that's dangerous it's
lethal
you're lucky to be alive come on Kamala
let em help you I'll take my chances
what if the Avengers were set up I think
you should see for yourself
mr. stark help us with this hi I'm sorry
who are you oh come on it's better be
good you try to drive the Chimera have
you completely lost your senses
where were you all the world what the
hell this is our fault bars you really
think the world is better without us yes
it's always been you truly running from
who you are what you are
[Music]
I will
with many
[Music]
we're here live with the aim experience
in Manhattan witnessing the return of
the Avengers footplate they appear to be
attacking the city keep rolling keep
rolling
[Music]
is it any coincidence that this attack
comes on the very day that aim is
supposed to unveil their promising new
adaptoid program Oh
you're welcome
thank you
[Music]
we're the terrorists in the same
experience story
[Music]
come on let's tone e we're trying to
restart the engines but there's not
enough power we're out of telling people
brace for impact
hey got a thunder light
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Marvel Avengers video
they just dropped a MODOK trailer with a
bunch of gameplay I'll also talk about
what's going on with MODOK inside the
MCU movies because he was originally
scheduled to appear during Marvel phase
four in one of the big movies so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos I will
do a giveaway for this videogame when
they release it but it's not coming out
till September so all you have to do to
enter that is just be a subscriber and
leave all your theories about MODOK
inside the MCU movies but the whole
thing with the Marvel Avengers game is
that MODOK and aim are revealed as the
main villains behind everything this
grand plan to take down the Avengers
Avengers disassembled big deep cut
Easter eggs he's trying to control
Inhumans which have been proliferating
all over the earth that's where miss
Marvel comes in because she's an inhuman
they're getting ready to do the Miss
Marvel Marvel phase for Disney Plus
series but they haven't announced a
release date for that yet they haven't
announced who they've cast as their new
Miss Marvel the robots that you see with
the Wolverine looking claws and the
trailer are the super adaptoid robots
from the comics they were also a
creation of aims that predated the debut
of MODOK in the comics so they actually
go way way back we also got a new look
at a comic book accurate version of the
abomination giving the Hulk the business
the abomination of the MCU looks a
little bit different who's still alive
for that matter Kevin Feige actually
revealed that a lot of the villains save
from The Incredible Hulk movie that they
haven't referenced in a while are still
chilling out in prison on the raft
somewhere everyone's hoping for that Red
Hulk Thunderbolt series at some point
with all those villains that the MCU has
on ice that they haven't killed off yet
it sounds like they're gonna do that at
some point but they haven't confirmed
that yet if you're not familiar with the
MODOK character that acronym stands for
mental mobile mechanized organism
designed only for killing his real name
as he appears earlier in the trailer
when he's still kind of in human form is
George Tarleton he worked for aim but in
the comics he actually debuted way back
in an Iron Man Captain America crossover
from tales of suspense his origin story
is a little bit weird so aim creates the
Cosmic Cube first which is something
from the Captain America comics
then they jack up George Tarleton with a
bunch of mutates turning him into
comic-book MODOK that giant floating
head they give him the name MODOK with a
C but it stands for mental organism
designed only for computing so they
designed him to be more of their puppet
to just solve really complex problems
but he rebels against them and takes the
name MODOK with a K changing the seat
for computing to K for killing MODOK
vows revenge against metahumans he hates
metahumans in the trailer here it's all
about Inhumans so it's a little bit
different but it's the same basic
concept so he battles aim for control
the organization then takes over way
back in the 70s he set off a giant nerve
agent in New York in another plot to get
rid of metahumans but miss marvel of the
1970s who's Carol Danvers teams up with
iron man at the time to stop him so you
can see the similarities in the plot of
The Avengers game to the original comics
they're basically doing a version of Moe
docs comic book story eventually in the
comics they wind up capturing him
throwing him in prison something like
the wrapped they offer him leniency if
he helps the Avengers in the US
government solve big problems and
disasters so they go to him every once
in a while but obviously there's been a
lot of subsequent MODOK stories since
then but he's mostly associated with the
aim organization in the MCU aim was a
creation of Aldrich Killian who was also
trying to get revenge against Iron Man
the whole thing with MODOK in the MCU is
that originally he was going to be the
main villain of ant-man 3 during Marvel
phase 4 or Marvel phase 5 depending on
how you want to think when that movie's
happening really I think it's closer to
being Marvel phase 5 but because MODOK
as a character is mostly used in comedic
stories recently because he is a giant
floating head which is kind of a silly
concept they were going to use him in
ant-man because that's mostly a comedic
movie series they didn't really say what
he was going to look like inside the MCU
we haven't seen concept art of it but
I'm assuming that they would have done a
version of his backstory so they could
have used the quantum realm and quantum
energy to mutate him into the giant
floating head from the comics way back
during ant-man and the wasp there was
that scene where Sonny birch said that
he wanted to get his hands on Hank PIMs
quantum technology in his lab for a
bidder that wouldn't take no for an
answer and had billions and billions of
dollars to spend so we all theorized
that could be No
Osborn Oscorp because there's just an
easy slam-dunk set up it could be a
fantastic for Easter egg it could be dr.
doom there's just a number of big
villains that they want to introduce in
the MCU that we know are coming
eventually that have that kind of money
to throw around but I think when MODOK
was going to be the villain of ant-man 3
it was gonna be MODOK who was behind
Sonny Burch and he was the one that
wanted to get his hands on the quantum
energy and that would have been the
continuation of the story line from
ant-man of the wasp what happened
recently though is they hired a new
writer to work on ant-man 3 it's not
going to be coming out for a couple
years so it's gonna be a while before I
hear more about that movie but it sounds
like now they're going in a different
direction and MODOK will not be the
villain so if we do see MODOK during
Marvel phase 4 it'll be somewhere else
in somebody else's movie or project in
fun deep cut Easter Egg some of you have
asked me what's going on with that new
warriors TV show that they were
developing a long time ago there was a
live-action squirrel girl in new
warriors TV show that when in
development years ago the showrunner
from that series said that it's been
cancelled since then but they had
originally intended for MODOK to be the
main villain of that series and it was
going to be Keith David himself voicing
the character they didn't release any
concept art for that but just the idea
of Keith David doing MODOK in a
live-action series sounds crazy it
wouldn't have been his face on screen
though it would have just been him doing
the voice for MODOK in some other way
for them to accomplish the visual MODOK
on screen but everyone let me know in
the comments what do you think about the
Avengers game I don't think it looks
quite as good as Spider Man ps4 or even
the Miles Morales game I know there are
a lot of theories that the Spider Man
ps4 character is gonna crossover with
the Avengers game I don't think that's
going to happen that's just a theory
that people have but nobody's confirmed
that I will also be doing a giveaway for
the Miles Morales spider-man PS 5 game
later this year but that's not going to
be released till after the Avengers game
that's gonna come out in September
there's a bunch of stuff that just
happened this week so I'll try to make
videos for everything leave all your
requests in the comments below
everyone click here to learn about
Michael Keaton coming back as Batman in
the new DC movies and click here to
watch that new spider-man Miles Morales
trailer in for new spider-man into the
spider-verse - thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]